[Applause]
[Music]
with the numbers in hand there is no
doubt
poland is experiencing the best era in
its entire history since 1989 when it
became the first country in the world to
completely abandon communism poland has
been experiencing an economic
miracle 1991 not exactly yesterday was
the last strictly bad year for the
polish economy until the arrival
of the coronavirus while in the rest of
europe there have been many ups and
downs along the way
since 1992 the polish economy has grown
each
and every year at an annual average rate
of over 4
neither the asian crisis nor the dot-com
crisis nor the great recession nor the
european debt crisis have made a dent in
the economic foundations of poland
man capitalism has a lot crises and even
now the impact of the corona virus
seems to be moderate poland's economy to
recover quickly after coronavirus crisis
imf pulse ski radio this is precisely
why in terms of purchasing power parity
that is taking price levels as a
reference the polish per capita income
is already practically at the level of
portugal
and very close to that of spain to give
you an idea since the fall of communism
the size of the polish economy has
increased
eightfold
and it's not just the gdp all indicators
have improved significantly until the
impact of the coronavirus
exports were going from strength to
strength job creation was breaking
records almost every new year
and as another example the productivity
of polish workers has increased by a
factor of three
since 1993. this is something like we
talked about here in a past video on
visualpolitik in a way
poland is becoming something like the
new germany of europe
maybe that is not the best example but
what it is is a new industrial and
export power
and all of this is a very very different
scenario to where it was in 1989
[Music]
the red boot
you see my friends between 1945 and 1989
that is for almost 45 long years poland
was under the control of the soviet
union during all that time the polls
could not choose the type of government
nor the political economic or social
model of their country
everything absolutely everything was
imposed from moscow through the
communist party of poland the so-called
polish united workers party however hold
on a moment
because even with all that it's clear
that the system in poland was one of the
least extreme
or totalitarian east of the iron curtain
there were several reasons for this
including international pressure the
fact that poles felt themselves to be
mostly central european citizens and
because civil society was stronger or
rather that it existed in some way
and that was already seeing a lot in
addition the catholic church had a lot
of influence in the country
and you could say that in some way it
gave shelter to very different ideas
from those that came from moscow
[Music]
well the point is that all these
elements allowed for some opposition to
exist and then polish people's republic
for movements such as the solidarity
union to emerge for land to be barely
collectivised or even for the polish
authorities to try their luck with the
introduction of market socialism a
political approach that consisted of
trying to apply market principles to
centrally planned economies
which in this case didn't really work
all that well
however despite everything despite
having a less radical or totalitarian
regime the 70s and 80s were also very
hard years both politically
and economically for example in the late
1980s the most popular expression was
nema there's none it was an expression
that was repeated over and over and over
again in the stores in the kiosks and in
the taverns because the lack of the most
basic products was so widespread
and if nema was perhaps the most popular
or at least the most repeated expression
one of the main activities in daily life
was queuing people spent hours and hours
in long lines waiting to buy some
product that was rumored to have arrived
at that establishment it seems
either have long lines for no food or
long lines for food they can't afford it
is difficult to find a witness account
about life and socialist poland that
does not refer precisely to these
immense cues
it's something that has been burned into
the collective imagination
then on top of the lack of products of
all kinds the long queues and the
electricity and water cuts
which were relatively frequent the
problem of inflation that practically
bordered on
hyperinflation levels that appeared at
the end of the 1980s you see my friends
almost 45 years after the
soviet-inspired socialist model was
first introduced the polish economy was
simply
shattered but at this point you're
probably thinking but grant if this was
the situation in poland in the late
1980s how could things change so quickly
how did poland go from being a
practically ruined economy to becoming
one of the greatest economic miracles in
europe
in the last 50 years how did the poles
manage to make the leap from communism
to capitalism if you want to know more
listen up
the transformation the balcerowicz plan
the economic crisis the growing
opposition and the openness to the west
promoted by mikhail gorbachev ended up
causing all the communist regimes to
begin falling apart
one by one poland was one of the first
on the first of january 1990 the first
technically post-communist government
began to implement a revolutionary
reform plan to change the country from
top
to bottom we are talking about one of
the most revolutionary and profound
economic reform programs ever undertaken
in the world and what was their goal to
transform as quickly as possible an
economy based on socialism central
planning and state ownership of the
means of production
into a pure capitalist economy it was
known as the balserowitz plan
an owner of lesnek balserowitz minister
of finance at the time the architect and
ideologue of this radical transformation
[Music]
legenek balcoritz was a young 42 year
old economist who had received his
doctorate from the central school of
planning and statistics in warsaw and
who had belonged to the powerful polish
united workers party until he decided to
leave it
in 1981. during his academic studies and
research while sarawitz had read
probably clandestinely works by mize and
hayek concerning the debate on socialism
it was something he said had a great
influence on his way of thinking through
them he took on their ideas that
property rights and free markets were
essential for a rational pricing system
to work
and for coordinating an economic system
in addition balsarowitz also studied in
detail the reforms of ludwig earhart the
german political leader who led the
changes that brought about the so-called
german economic miracle of the federal
republic of germany after the
devastation of world war ii
well weaving together all those threads
while sarawitz set out to turn poland
upside down
and he succeeded
at the end of august 1989 the prime
minister of the first post-communist
government
tadius mazawiki offered balzerowitz the
position of deputy prime minister and
minister of finance in the hopes of
reproducing in poland what had been
achieved in the federal republic of
germany you see my friends it was the
only way not only to escape poverty and
regain prosperity but also to save the
fledgling democracy
we are faced with a dramatic alternative
either we continue to march towards a
better economy or we give up all the
achievements already made and returned
to chaos
lescek balcerowicz before the polish
parliament while arguing for his
adjustment plan remember that at the
time the collapse of the old communist
political systems was becoming an even
more acute crisis
in just two years industrial production
in poland had fallen by almost 40
percent hyperinflation was looming and
almost 1.5 million people had lost their
jobs
the collapse was total and scarcity was
the most common denominator but having
said that what exactly was the plan that
was designed to save poland
you see the balcerous plan sought to do
many things at once on the 6th of
october 1989 it was presented on
television
and in december a comprehensive package
of 11 laws was passed in parliament that
would change the history of poland
forever the first was the act on
financial economy within state-owned
companies
and remember that at the time
state-owned companies dominated the vast
majority of the polish economy an
example of this law was that it required
companies to be managed according to
market criteria and allowed large public
companies to declare bankruptcy if they
were not self-sufficient they would have
to be reorganized
or liquidated then the second law was
the act on banking law that among other
things
prohibited the central bank from
financing the government's deficit and
greatly restricted the creation of new
money in other words
it stopped the banknote printing machine
and its tracks
[Music]
next came the act on credits and the act
on taxation of excessive wage rise
which eliminated the privileges public
enterprises had to receive credits and
prevented public wages from growing
excessively the new tax law introduced
among other changes
a common taxation for all companies by
abolishing the surcharges and special
taxes that were imposed on private
companies and by eliminating the
privileges that public corporations had
foreign direct investment exports
imports profit repatriation capital
inflow and outflow and the conversion of
the national currency
this lotte into foreign currency were
also almost completely liberalised
and the act on customs law created a
single uniform rate applicable to all
companies
public or private
and not only that price controls were
also eliminated along with many of the
subsidies that the state was
distributing everywhere the labor market
was made more flexible and even for the
most distrustful foreign investors a 100
guarantee of the investment was
established in case of expropriation and
of course a plan was put in place to
privatize public companies and many of
the government's properties
all this was set in motion practically
overnight and although it may be
surprising to you
the support for the measures which in
many cases was going to involve many
difficulties for a considerable time
was enormous to give you an idea at that
time the perception that polish citizens
had was that the only thing keeping them
from prosperity was the communist system
so the faster it was overthrown and
replaced the better it would be for
everyone of course at this point many of
you may be wondering okay
okay this is all well and good but these
economies were based on public ownership
most of the productive factors belong to
the state so in other words what on
earth happened to these public trading
centers
well let's take a look at that right now
the public giants
[Music]
it is clear that the dominance of public
companies in poland in 1989 was almost
total we are talking about a hardcore
model of communism precisely because of
this initially there were some
if not most economists and analysts who
consider that the key step in the
transition of these countries would be
the transformation of the public sector
as some of you may know
public companies tend to have different
problems to private ones problems with
incentives exchange rates
costs etc for example let's take a look
at the case of the polish shipyards
[Music]
polish shipyards were controlled by
essential planning agencies they did not
have a global approach to ensure
workloads each shipyard built all kinds
of ships in other words they were not
specialized and were also inefficient
they also had very inflated cost
structures and many more employees than
they actually needed the result was that
they were money losing machines whose
upkeep cost the state a fortune
because they depended not on selling
ships but on government subsidies
[Music]
and of course the problem is that
turning such a hulking ship around
is difficult managers were used to
dealing with state bureaucrats not to
competing in the market and winning
contracts
productivity was at rock bottom in fact
less than a quarter of the productivity
of shipyards in other countries like
south korea japan
or even china incentives were there to
maintain the model not to change it and
so on
in any case the point was that yes
poland implemented a privatization and
restructuring plan however the most
striking thing about this particular
model is that in the transition
all of this was almost irrelevant you
see the reforms promoted in the
balceroids plan
generated such dynamism that in the end
the big drivers of the change were the
new
small and medium enterprises that
suddenly sprouted like mushrooms while
the restructuring and privatization of
the large public giants advanced slowly
the new private economy took off
so strongly that by 1994 about 2 million
private companies and businesses were
already responsible for almost
half of all non-agricultural employment
in the country
and my friends the results are clear
check this out
the results
top marks outstanding definitely an
honorable mention this is the grade we'd
give to the transformation of poland
you see as it turned out the crisis
resulting from the change of model was
very short-lived despite the collapse of
almost all the country's institutions in
barely six years the gdp had already
recovered completely and poland then
began a period of uninterrupted growth
that has only been slowed down
occasionally by the coronavirus almost
30 years later by 1999
poland's gdp was already 20 higher than
it had been in 1989 and business
activity was skyrocketing
[Music]
and it wasn't only commercial activity
foreign direct investment began to pour
into the country in huge quantities in
1989 for example poland attracted no
less than 40
of all foreign direct investment flows
into eastern europe
[Music]
these companies you see on screenware
some of the multinationals that invested
the most in the country
anyway my friends this is how poland's
success story began which now sees it
closer to countries like portugal or
even spain 30 years on this is how
poland overcame communism by undergoing
a kind of overnight shock therapy
however the reforms continued
including a comprehensive health care
reform in 1999 based on private service
providers as well as a complete reform
of the pension system where
capitalization elements were introduced
but perhaps the thing that is most
striking in the case of poland is that
no government
no one has reversed the pro-market
reforms that have been pushed by
previous governments
not bad right but having given you the
overview it's now
over to you what do you think of such
abrupt changes do you think the polish
model could serve in some way
as a reference for many countries with
similar problems leave your answer
in the comments below so we really hope
you enjoyed this video please hit like
if you did and don't forget to subscribe
for brand new videos
also don't forget to check out our
friends at the reconsider media podcast
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not my dulcet tones finally
this channel is possible because of
patreon and our patrons on that platform
please consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage
and as always i'll see you next time and
if you want to learn more about politics
and hear
even more of my lovely voice you can
join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider media.com
podcast see you there